hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000
as always my name is caleb denby and
tonight i have a pretty fun topic for
you it's going to be a more instruct
instructive night than last week we are
going to be talking about
the difference between grand master
level players
and players around my strength maybe
even a little
little stronger um i find these games
really really interesting
to look at because in these grand master
versus grand master games a lot of times
the the play is at such a high level
they're making all kinds of decisions
that a player like me and a player like
you might not
really run across whereas it's
super instructive to see how players at
your level or even a little bit above
um lose games consistently because
grandmasters of course
consistently beat players like me that's
just the way it is
uh over the board and so we're gonna
look at these games and we're gonna see
if there's anything we can take away
uh to work on in uh my chest and your
chest
to be able to compete with these super
strong players a little bit better
so let's switch over to this
hopefully everything is up and running
and i actually want to start with this
game
uh between of course one of the top us
players var okobian and a player by the
name of
kazim gulamali now you've probably never
heard
of var kobien's opponent here because uh
i don't believe he's that strong of a
chess player he's around i think the
2200 feet a mark
which of course is still very very good
but you know nothing
to var ocobian so to
uh probably most of the viewers and even
to myself
it's hard to imagine a 2200 feed a
player
uh kind of going down without a fight or
really
consistently uh losing to to anybody
but that's what we're going to see here
between
gula mali and okobin so let's try and
figure out how it happens
uh gula mali starts with e4 and now we
get d6
um and so var already
has adopted a pretty interesting
approach
in the form of the pierce
now his opponent goes d4 and we actually
seen out of six
the main line so far and rather than
the super main line with knight to c3
gulamali actually shows this move
pawn to f3 which is perfectly acceptable
but it is uh more of a sideline than
knight c3 perhaps a little bit more
conservative
defending the e4 pawn with the f3 pawn
pretty much saying to black no i i don't
want to ever launch this pawn out to f4
and go for some of those more active
lines against the pierce and now var is
going to make a really interesting
decision here so sort of the quote
unquote normal way to play would be to
strike back in the center now
with the move e5 you can also uh think
about fianchettoing this bishop
or think about challenging the center
with the pawn uh
with the c pawn going pawn c5 to hit d4
before it actually plays this move d5
which is of course a little bit more off
the beaten path it's not often you see
this little stutter step by the d-pawn
losing a little bit
bit of time early in the opening uh
here i think var can get away with it
because you know like ben feingold says
you should never play f3 and
uh while it is a useful uh supporting
move for this pawn on e4
we're gonna see that var is able to
waste just a little bit of time
because white can't get active quite as
quickly because this pawn on
f3 is sort of hindering white's own
development this knight is going to
struggle
to find a good square with this pawn on
f3 taking away its most natural
developing square now that being said
after d5
uh how do you think white should react
chat room
what should uh white try to go for
what should we go for here
so yeah gabriel has the right idea and i
think it's the most intuitive move uh
rey actually suggests the move played in
the game which is e takes d5
and this move is okay but generally you
know you you
have the ability to take space in the
opening and
uh when you get that ability you
generally should
take it uh sometimes you'll see both
players sort of dancing around the
center not
fully committing to a ton of space but
here e5 is just i think the best idea
you kick black's knight around and you
also
get to make this beautiful pawn center
hampering blacks pieces and you know be
it a psychological
thing or maybe just google molly
preferred the position
after e takes d5 we do get e takes d5
instead
of e5 and that's the first thing i kind
of want to talk about
is at all levels of chess i think people
tend to play a little bit
differently when they're playing a
player who's higher rated than them
who's better than them at chess
uh versus someone who's a little bit
lower rated than them or even
at the same string and there seems to be
a tendency to want to
simplify things uh go for something you
know easier that you think you can
understand just as well
and i'm of the mindset that's uh it's
better just just to play your best chess
so do what you think is best and if you
end up losing because it's complicated
then you at least hopefully you've
learned something from it so i'm not a
huge fan of e takes d5
i feel like it is unnecessarily trying
to simplify things and it definitely is
kind of giving away the advantage that
var had offered up like e5
is definitely a fight for an advantage
whereas this move now
uh we're gonna see that white doesn't
quite get that central dominance
that we would have seen with e5 that
being said uh white does have some good
ideas here
this knight has been drawn out to the d5
square
so we're going to see c4 in an effort to
push it away
now knight b6 and knight c3 is all
fairly normal
so far so if you are varacobian
and you are sort of the the favorite
here by 300 plus points
uh what do you want to do now to uh
fight back in this opening and give
yourself some chances
to uh to win this game perhaps
we need a good idea for black here
something strong
something strong
and the chat room is correct once again
with the exact same idea that uh
we saw for the other site a few moves
ago it's kind of funny i asked the
chatroom two questions and the answer
both times
it of course was the move e5
now surprised kind of that the chat came
up with this so quickly because this is
a pure pawn sacrifice that you are not
going to be getting this pawn back
anytime soon
but var doesn't care here uh because var
understands
sort of the weakness that white has
created by playing this move f3 so early
on
uh by by playing this move the
huge uh problem that white is going to
run into here
isn't necessarily that uh
you know that that weakens squares which
it does now in this case the problem is
that
white has to waste a lot of time now to
get the pieces totally developed
we're gonna see that after white accepts
this pawn sacrifice which
playing something like d5 would sort of
just feel a little bit bad here
you don't really have great control over
these dark squares on the queen side
and uh black now has a nice pawn in the
center as well
so don't really like the move d5 that's
why we see d takes e5
instead var is
not unhappy to trade uh trade the queens
here
we see knight takes d1 trying to
preserve the king's
castling rights in this case and now var
simply plays knight c6
hitting this pawn on e5 there's really
only one comfortable way to defend it
and that is with the move f4
and now we see bishop e6 so
already out of the opening var has
managed to create
some intrigue uh is one way to put it
meaning
var has in fact sacrificed a full pawn
here but in return
he has three full pieces developed and
white
has all of their pieces on the back row
so we're going to see now that once an
imbalance has been created
generally the gm's are just going to
find the better way
to navigate the complications and in
this case
i think it's simply a a matter of
opening understanding var had prepared
this opening i'm
fairly confident he didn't just come up
with this uh totally on the fly
and this position has been reached
before in the database and i'm
reasonably certain that gula molly had a
lot less
prep and a lot less knowledge going into
this game
uh ray says bishop five is better i have
to disagree
because this move is actually coming
with tempo
actually coming with tempo so here
already
uh on move 10 we're gonna see white
start to make mistakes
so it might not seem like white is in
all that much danger
uh in the position because queens have
been traded off the board white is up
for the moment a healthy pawn and you
don't immediately see
how black is creating too many threats
but with that being said
it turns out that time very much is of
the essence here
and white needs to play pretty
accurately to not be worse out of this
opening
so ray suggests b3 for white but this is
actually the mistake
played in the game b3 is not going to be
a great
move here for white and the reason
is uh it's simply a little bit too slow
i mean you're already down
three pieces in development and after
queen side castles by black black's king
is out of the center
and the rook is already on an active
open file
and you're just sort of falling further
and further behind in development
so what's a much better move than b3
for white there is something a lot
better
something better here than b3
what's to do chatroom what to do
and yeah kyle has the right idea it's
simply 93 here
and the point is yes we are defending
our pawn but we're also getting
developed
um and here queenside castles is
perfectly reasonable for black
bishop c5 would also be a move to keep
up the pressure and then i think for
white it's honestly just best
to sacrifice this pawn back you don't
need to
go all in trying to maintain your extra
pawn
something like this is perfectly
reasonable
just leveling the playing field in terms
of development
keeping your space advantage in the
center uh and giving back the pawn
and i think this is something that gm's
are a lot better at
doing than you know a 2200 level player
2200 feet a um
and i think it's really really pivotal
to these kinds of games
you know i know for myself in particular
once you have one kind of advantage
uh you tend to want to just like stick
with that right like
you're like this is my extra pawn this
is what i'm gonna try to hold on to to
try to win this game
and this fluidity is actually really
really important uh
at the higher levels of chess you need
to be willing to give back
a material advantage to get your pieces
developed
or give up your extra development in
return
for some material in some cases
and so here we see that var has just
navigated those complications a bit
better
than uh then white has white going for
b3 now the game definitely isn't over
but after queen side castles i think
black is definitely on the offensive at
this point
white does continue with the move knight
e3
and simply bishop c5 var completes
development
no need to do anything too crazy uh just
yet
and now chat room i would like you to
find
a move for whites wait to move here and
i
uh suspect that not many people are
going to come up
with the move that uh that was played by
white
in the game because it just doesn't make
too much sense
chat room says is it just me or is it
super laggy i sure hope not
uh everything looks good on my end for
the moments
might be on your end
but i don't know
rey says a5 that seems highly illegal
pawns can't move that far i promise they
don't go that far
one square at a time two squares if it's
your first turn
it is not black to play white to play
this should be e2 or king of three i
assume you mean king of two or maybe you
mean knight f3
knight before on the horizon for black
streaming for new location yeah i am
upstairs and at the uh
at the chess club today
92 has been suggested so yeah you guys
are
along the right track here um you need
to
develop your pieces and i think you know
looking
back that's probably a really really
simple idea
is like yeah okay i mean i have to
develop my pieces here but looks like
bishop
e2 moves like knight f3 uh these
you know it's sort of getting desperate
for white here you need
to play these moves before it's too late
but i think some psychology came into
play here again
kyle mentioned this idea of knight b4
and was a little bit afraid
of this plan involving maybe captures on
e3
something like knight c2 check and so
white
seeing this coming plays the move a3 and
this move is
is simply too much it's just too much
you can't have one two three four five
pieces developed and uncastled
king and play the move play the move a3
you just cannot do it there's no pawn in
the world that's going to be enough
compensation here if you continue
wasting tempe
um and after this black is simply just
winning out of the opening
so a move like knight f3 would have kept
the game going
move like bishop e2 also would have kept
the game going
but uh we do need to find a response to
this idea
of knight to b4 so what do you think our
response should be
what should our response be to this
knight before idea
not the easiest problem to solve
definitely not the easiest
king f1 rook b1 these moves are all very
slow
they're very very slow um i don't want
to spoil
why they're the worst moves just yet but
they are a bit too slow to be any good
and we'll look at why in a little bit
here so gabriel
has the right idea once again it's going
to be
flexibility that's the key in this game
and that's what white was just missing
white has the extra pawn wanted to keep
the extra pawn
and wanted to uh you know sort of play
to keep this
and if white keeps this then maybe white
is a lot better
but that's just not how chess works
right the p the pawn wasn't actually
free
black got a lot of development in
exchange for it and so if you're not
willing
to give it back to finish your own
development
then you might end up significantly
worse so
knight f3 is actually the best move and
then after
bishop takes e3 we simply play bishop
takes e3
and king f2 and
white is not at all worse in this
position in fact
white would be quite a bit better with
the two bishops and the powerful pawn
center
in this instance this knight on p6 is
simply useless
uh these bishops are going to be strong
c5 is on the horizon as well as
these king side pushes and he five is
also going to be a good move and white
is just significantly better here
after the exchange sacrifice now what's
wrong with rook b1 well let's take a
look at what happens
in the game first rather than develop we
see
white play this move a3 so
this is where white makes the mistake
and then
one mistake is oftentimes uh
enough to to lose the game against a
player like varakovian so
how do we punish white's mistake is it
time
for tactics or is it time to uh
to keep it going exchange stack doesn't
work here run it through an engine
believe it or not ray i do occasionally
prep for my classes
and that position was about plus one for
whites according
to stockfish 13.
um so you're welcome to check for
yourself on that one
but that one pretty good for white
okay we've got some ideas knight d4
knight a5
both being suggested
bishop d4 has been suggested
and yeah these moves are probably all uh
reasonable for black but
i like what var did does kind of the
best there's actually
a more tactical uh knockout blow here
so white was better until that point no
white wasn't better black of course
should not capture the exchange and
continue playing for
uh development the point being
was that white needed to get developed
in this position
and that was white's chance to keep the
game in the balance
and then it was actually a bit of a trap
for black if black gets too greedy and
tries to take the exchange then white's
going to end up better
black has to keep the dynamics flowing
so matthew
actually has the tactical way to uh
seize a huge advantage with the move f6
but
var being a professional here says i'm
going to develop my rook
first and plays the move rook h to e8
and these
f6 rookie 8 ideas are uh
how black is breaking through in this
position
uh you may have spent a tempe stopping
knight b4
but var is going to continue
multi-purpose moves developing
and creating threats at the same time
and there's only so long
you can survive on the back row once
black has all the pieces in the game
we see knight f3 by white and of course
now the idea is f6
and white is simply busted here uh
e takes f6 was tried in the game and
what's the winning move
in this position chat room what's the
winning move here
black to move and win no uh crazy
tactics here
it's just uh it's it's just
sad it's just sad for for white
oh and i've started fights in the chat
room once again it's so sad
it's so sad
bishop takes pawn not quite why
sacrifice a piece
when you can simply retreat it keep the
peace and still have the same tactics so
bishop g8 is var's move and this one is
going to be enough to win the game
um there's simply no good way to defend
this knight you have
two options and both of them remain in
pretty nasty pins white picked the weird
king e2
but king f2 honestly wouldn't have made
much of a difference here
after king e2 var simply takes back on
f6
taking his time whites pretends that
someday is going to develop
and then the last move of the game is
actually the
very clever move knight to a5 the point
now
being that if you try to play b4 i take
on e3
take on e3 take on c4 and this pawn
or this bishop dies and if you try to
defend the pawn
i can simply capture and win
material like this so basically white's
whole queen slide is completely falling
apart
and the center is completely falling
apart and white
never even gets developed in this game
so this
is the first type of win i wanted to
show you
between a grand master and you know a
master level player
uh and this is sort of the saddest kind
of game you're gonna find where
white just never really got off the
ground you know what i mean
whites uh was a little bit too rigid in
the opening whites you know got this
extra pawn
and then wasn't willing to adapt to the
situation and that is a skill
that is very very hard to develop and
that's why
uh gm's are so much better at it than uh
than master level players it's just so
tough to know
when you should sort of hold on to what
you've got and when you need
to throw it all away to get your pieces
out
with bishop g4 work instead of bishop g8
probably i think there are a lot of
winning moves here
for uh black i think why var didn't do
it is perhaps
concerns over this move f7 probably var
wants to keep
the f7 square defended so we don't have
to make a decision with this rook
uh bishop f7 i'm sure is also fine but
maybe var was
looking to avoid knight g5 with tempo
just bishop g8 is the simplest you get
the bishop out of the way
and the tactics speak for themselves
the way this game played out it's like
is white really a master so so yeah it's
very different when you're sitting
across the board
from you know a 2200 feet a player it's
very very different
than than this game it goes to show just
how strong
these grand masters actually are they
understand the nuances
of their positions they understand when
they need to be flexible
they understand how to navigate
imbalances and so that's the first
type of game i wanted to show um before
i move on are there any questions here
because there seem to be doubts over
uh over this position so uh i guess i
should address
what should black do here if not night
before going for
this knight c2 stuff well it turns out
black is still going to be a lot better
here
by attacking the center staying true to
the original plan
not getting sidetracked with spending
for tempe winning winning an exchange
when white's going to use those for
tempe
to develop the rest of their pieces um
so hopefully that answers some of those
questions uh
with that out of the way let's move on
to another us chess legend
um art can you be a legend if you're
still like
you know playing and having a career i
don't know
uh i'll call him legends for now u.s
champion sam
shanklin with the black pieces here uh
up against rental
negrenda uh who is 2265 another 22 2300
level player
up against just an absolute monster
where was white's last chance to keep
fighting and stay in the game
so i'll just briefly step back here
looking from white's perspective
a3 is when the game really goes in the
dumpster if you play something like
knight f3 here
you're still in the game uh i think
black is probably a little bit better
uh because of just the sheer amounts of
develop development
white is going to have to give some
stuff back eventually
but if you get the pieces developed you
get the king to f2
you get the rooks in the center then you
do have a fair shot
at this game you just have to absolutely
develop as quickly as possible
after a3 though pretty much busting all
right let's move on we're looking at
rentalla versus sam shankland we get a
sicilian
and rantala plays b3 so once again
um i understand being afraid of the you
know
prep of a player like sam shankland but
i think it
is uh a bit better to just play what you
are comfortable with and maybe for
rental this is b3 but
to my eyes b3 looks like a sideline that
you kind of pull out when you want
things to be a little bit calmer but
maybe i've got it all wrong i don't know
that for a fact
but anyways we get b3 and sam plays e6
um once again far off the beaten path
already by move two
bishop b2 now b6 and we are very very
far off the beaten path now
with sam being kettling this bishop and
just adopting
a very simple very solid setup in the
center
uh knight c3 bishop b7 and both sides do
actually manage to complete development
this game
so already a step up from the previous
example
and here we see white going for pretty
standard ideas
in 1v3 type openings in this case b3
wasn't played till move two
but white is sort of staying true to the
b3 idea you
uh occasionally try to get rid of this
bishop for this knight and
play for control over the dark squares
activating
this bishop on b2 i i taught a whole
lecture on this plan
uh way back in the day for those long
term fans
so my question to you now is as sam
shankland
what are you going to do against this
move bishop
b5 continue developing or is there
something else you can do
as you see me i'm actually sitting by a
window here and there were
some protests going on earlier today and
i think someone just drove by that was
part of it
oh all the positivity in the chat all
the positivity
bishop e7 knight f6 d5 well
first of all you want to be a little bit
careful playing bishop b7 um
whenever you leave this pawn undefended
it does just get a little bit scary
although it's probably perfectly fine
here
um but i do like pranith's idea
a lot better it's really really useful
at all levels of chess to understand
what your opponent's plan is
what they are you know trying to do and
if you can sort of steer the game in a
direction
where they are not able to do that that
can be very very useful uh we saw var
kind of do it
just by you know playing a very very
offbeat opening
in this game we see sam doing that with
the move knight to d4
i think this is very much an attempt to
get white out
of this plan that they're probably
comfortable with right
uh because if you just play a simple
move like knight f6
uh let's say we get like castles bishop
e7
um even like d3 or something
a6 something like this i think this is
sort of
what white is more uh more familiar with
in the b3 plants you play for the dark
squares you give up the bishop
for the night and you try to find an
advantage
like this uh whereas with the move
knight d4
all of a sudden uh white is gonna have
to adapt that plan
entirely uh no longer are you getting
rid of this knight
and in fact if you ever take on d4 it's
gonna be black with control over the
dark squares in the center
so already uh sam is doing some things
to get the opponent a little bit off
balance
we see castles by whites knight f6 by
black
applying a little bit of pressure this
bishop comes on back
to d3 to defend the e4 pawn they should
be seven now
and ricky one
and now knight takes d4 by
white so already you see
that uh black is actually going to be a
little bit better
out of the opening but i want to stress
that this is a very different
uh you know method of getting an
advantage than what we saw
in vars game in var's game var very much
took a
you know riskier approach he went for a
very imbalanced position
and kept putting on the pressure until
the opponent kind of cracked
in this case the mistakes are coming
from white seemingly unprovoked
by sam shanklin and i think this is
actually the more common way you see
gm's uh beating players of this strength
uh there's a good rule in chess and that
rule
is that you know your opponent can't
make any mistakes
if you're forcing them to play sort of
only moves
so sometimes by creating more threats
and by keeping up
you know all this pressure pressure
pressure you're actually making your
opponent's job very very easy
they simply have to find the only move
that is reasonable
and when they do then they're still okay
whereas in a position like this sam has
given his opponent a lot of
options here white could think about
playing for e5
white could think about rerouting this
knight and playing something like c3d4
white could even i don't know
potentially do something on the queen
side
or why could capture in the center and
the fact of the matter is
when you're a grandmaster with more
experience in these positions
you're going to be able to know you know
which of these options are good and
which of these options are bad
and players at the 2200 level you're
simply not going to be as good at
making these kinds of open-ended
decisions
so what am i trying to say i'm saying
gm's
are the scariest when it seems like you
have a lot of
options because then you have to
actually decide for yourself and in this
case
white decides somewhat wrong here with
ct or knight takes d4
uh black is simply going to be better
after c takes e4
because number one we hit this knight
with tempo and after knight b5
we can shore up our central position
here with the pawn
on e5 now
i want to flip flip the script a little
bit we're going to look from white's
point of view
and i'm going to ask you uh a kind of
loaded question
so as white what are you afraid of
in this position what are you afraid of
here
your opponent just played e5 you're
playing sam shankland who at the time of
this game
was not us champion but uh was a future
us champion
at the time of this game uh what are you
afraid of what do you think sam's up to
here
so yeah de chun has a a good idea here
um you're afraid of the b7 bishop so
yeah
that this is what we're sort of arriving
at black is making a pretty serious
threat in this position
and that threat is to play the move d5
uh as
kyle anderson said in the chat
activating along these light squares and
sort of breaking open
the position so white black is playing
d5 or at least this is one of black's
ideas
so what should we do about it how do we
deal with this threat
of pawn d5 white knight b5
isn't 92 better knight p5 is is actually
a pretty reasonable
idea here for uh reasons
that we shall soon see also 92
is maybe okay but you do have to realize
you're temporarily interfering with
your control over the e4 square so maybe
it's okay
because you're counter-attacking here
and you'd play knight g3 out of the way
but something to think about there with
the
the pawn on e4 as well
so yeah i've successfully led the chat
room to to say the wrong move thank you
all for for playing along i know you all
realized that c4 is probably a bad move
uh but thank you for playing along with
my line of questioning
so c4 was played in the game and you
don't need to be an armchair
psychologist
to know why this move was played uh
rotala was just simply afraid
of d5 and why wouldn't you be sam is
threatening to activate everything like
let's say you play some slow move like
h3
black is just going to break out with d5
if you take this piece
queen takes d5 and you're already like
you you're so busted here
you are getting so busted
uh on the king's side you have to play
like f3 or something awful
bishop f1 is leading to
these pawns rolling down the board and
it's just
it's just so so sad um if i flip on the
engine here
let's see it's only no wait it's like
equal
wait this is ridiculous this is
ridiculous
okay okay i can do better i can do
better i can do better
a3 putting this knight on a bad square
and then d5
i was like yeah wait a second isn't
bishop f1 fine but after we kicked this
knight away yes so this is the line i
was talking about where
black is rolling down the center you
just have to get rid of this knight
first
to defend your d4 pawn and so of course
now this actually does look bad
uh i'm not just scamming you glad i
checked
so d5 very very scary if you play a slow
move like h3 you could just be losing
right away uh so high weed suggests
queen f3
this is another reasonable idea but
you're still gonna get sort of
busted by this move d5 i think this
bishop is going to come through now
onto the e4 square hitting this queen
with tempo
and uh i don't know how long for this
world uh your position's
going to be okay again we should
probably include this
but uh once again e4 breaking through
and sam is just taking over the entire
center
so you know when you're sitting there
and you're calculating
with the white pieces and you're like oh
i'd like to play queen f3 but
okay no looks like it loses uh maybe i
can play something slow like h3
know that that also just loses um you
start to
sort of convince yourself that c4 is
your only option
uh but chat room why is c4
bad uh and also what should we do
differently
so let's answer that question first what
should we do other than c4
something more active
more active deschoon has a suggestion
suggestion
with f4 anything else
that we could try
what else could we try here to activate
the pieces
okay now everybody wants to play f4
so kyle has the move that i was fishing
for f4 is actually also a really nice
idea but the move c3 is a little bit
more to my liking just
just because you know what i hate moving
my f
i just hate it you know i play f3 in
like every opening but sometimes
i hate moving my f pawn as well just
weakens a lot of squares
so c3 i think is the best idea here for
white although f4 is another very viable
way
to you know try and challenge the center
um so just for example c3 let's say
black does play this move a6
and go d5 uh what was our point
what's the big idea here
what's the big idea knight takes d4 that
would be a little bit much that would be
losing a piece
uh hello dave yes dave the first person
in the chat to point out that uh i cut
all my hair off
this is my first haircut uh class
so of course we need to fight back in
the center here in
all the other lines we were having to
sort of deal with this threat to the e4
pawn by capturing
that was activating our opponent's
pieces in this case we are simply
fighting back in the center
using our c pawn so yeah c takes d4 and
when the dust settles
uh white is going to be perfectly okay
here we see this nice bishop against
this knight
but really both sides are going to have
some activity here and potentially this
d3 pawn
is more of a weakness than an ass set
for example
knight c4 heading to e5 and white is
going to be able to activate
uh comfortably here um and it's not
quite a quality black is going to be a
little bit better with this super strong
bishop
but you know white is still in the game
white finds activity
um so
c3 i think was the best idea for white
here
instead we see the move c4 so i i've
sort of said
you know just and because you guys trust
me you believe me
that's um this is a bad move uh but
let's try and understand
why c4 is so bad uh what
should black be doing to uh
to take advantage of this move c4
what should black be doing
and apparently i have some youtube
celebrity in my chat i get the feeling
it's probably not the real account if i
had to guess
generally there's a check mark by these
people's names when they are the real
ones
um vishwash i think in that line if you
go queen takes d3
i still take on f6 and then you actually
have
trouble uh recapturing because you don't
control that square quite enough time so
you have to fracture your pawns
so derek's is locked down the position
to kill the light squared bishop
and that's sort of the trick of it um
you don't really have to do anything
to lock down the bishop and kill the
light's great bishop white sort of did
that for you and not only did white kill
the
light-squared bishop white also kind of
killed the dark squared bishop with this
move
so that's why c4 is so bad it just
becomes
very very difficult for white to
activate the pieces and i mean it's not
a totally lost cause you can imagine
f4 someday trying to rip things open or
this bishop finding a new diagonal
somewhere
but the fact of the matter is it's going
to take white a long long time to
activate these pieces
and in the meantime black is going to
come up with an active plan
so to start with perhaps anticipating f4
ideas and just because it gives you a
little bit more space in general
we do see black play this move d6
and then after knight a3 we need to
launch an
active idea so what can we do with the
black pieces here to take
advantage of white's inactivity what's
our game plan
in the long run
what's our game plan here
what to do
so yeah great wolf is mentioning that uh
he was perhaps relying on the f4 break
to activate this bishop
and that's part of the problem with uh
white's position
is this pawn on d6 is actually very very
useful for black because after f4
black of course isn't going to take on
f4 they're just going to let the the
pawn sit
and then if you take simply pawn takes
e5 again and you're in the exact same
predicament as
the four
so you guys are along the right track
and i think harry
gates is the first one to find the uh
sort of exact way
that uh black went about it in this case
knight h5 would as ben feingold puts it
be
risky so knight d7 instead is the better
idea
and we're not really pushing g5 first
but we are looking to push f5
of course activating this bishop along
this long diagonal
again reviving our plans of pushing our
central pawns
and overwhelming the white position uh
and just attacking on the king's side
and pyman also has the right idea in
building it up a little bit first we're
not going to play it right away
but we are looking to play it uh white
plays this move bishop back to f1 while
they can
since this pawn is defended and now
simply knight c5
activates the knight further we see pawn
to d3
and white or black plays another
preparatory move in the form of queen d7
before launching into this f5 idea just
improving the pieces
and even visually you can see that black
should just be much better here without
doing any kind of calculating or even
like finding the plans
you see a strong knight on c5 you see
this bishop and queen both with open
ideas
and you see white's pieces just sort of
scattered
around the board and kind of aimless
if i had to describe them in a word uh
white tries to move g3 here which is
as good a try as any to activate the
bishop this way and now
sam shanklin simply plays the move f5
uh and this is just going to be tough
for white now white is already
i would say lost positionally bishop h3
was white's idea and he sticks with it
um but now we actually see black
rerouting again
with this move knight e6 and uh sort of
daring
white to actually capture this pawn on
f5
of course black has some ideas here in
the form of just giving up this rook
playing knight g5 and with these
powerful pieces on the light squares
white is like checkmated basically
um basically just just checkmated here
we're not even gonna play knight f3 to
take the rook on e1 we're gonna play
knight f3 and then bring the queen in
and then you know deliver checkmate to
the white king
um so bishop takes f5 simply unplayable
bishop c1 was played instead um rental
showing a little bit of chest strength
here is like yeah no i'm not playing
bishop f5
sam shanklin is just going to murder me
in this position
but now simply takes on e4 takes on e4
black has a target
an open f file and an active way to
bring in all the pieces so
rick f6 why not bring in another rook
we get rook g6 and now we're at f8 and
now knight c2
and sam simply unpins to bring in the
final pieces
uh we get knight b4 finally this knight
has completed its journey and is heading
for the powerful d5 square it only took
one two three four five
and going to be six moves uh so we get
bishop g5
and now knight d5 and how do we convert
this
as sam shanklin how do we convert this
how to convert this position
so sam actually picks a pretty simple
way to convert here
now that the knight has spent six moves
getting to d5
you might as well take it um sam first
takes on d2 though we get take on e6
take e6 taking d2
and then simply bishop takes d5 and that
goes to show you how bad white's
position really is right you spend
six moves getting the knight to a good
square and then it just gets captured by
a bishop that moved twice
um and this is just the end of the game
now we see e takes d5
queen h3 and now white doesn't have
enough space on the king's side to deal
with these problems
by the way black also has a protected
pass pawn in the form of d4
and there's just no recovering at this
point rookie four was played
rook h6 was played which isn't even the
best but it's good enough
um f4 is the only way to defend the h2
pawn
so simply captures and now uh
once again you you cannot take this guy
back if you take with the rook
i'll take back and if you take the pawn
then you get checked
and checkmated same with the rook
you can't take with the queen of course
because of checkmate
and here it's the same issue um so
can't capture this pawn back white plays
queen g2 simply f takes g now
and we see the queens are still on the
board
and black is just up material now and
white is still checking it
uh we do get to see a nice finish after
h5
rook takes d4 we get queen c1 check
rookie one
and what's the last move of the game
chat room black to move and win here
black to move and win
this move is so good that rintala had to
resign
uh yeah this is an excellent point uh we
do have connect four for white
yes so the chat room sees it it's rook
f1
and checkmate to follow
or at least a few extra pieces
a few extra pieces for black so after
rook f1 check out white simply resigned
this game
so what happened here well what happened
is
sam did the very very mean thing of
giving his opponent
some options right a little bit of
pressure in the form of threatening to
play d5
but really at this point white sort of
sealed his own fate by playing knight
takes d4
now black is already a little bit better
and you absolutely have to play for
activity
as quickly as you can you can't be
afraid
play the the move pawn c4 like this
you just get crushed by sam shanklin
so in short what's the difference
between gm's
and master level players well gm's are
better at chess
but really it's about this kind of
flexibility
that gm's have and it's about having the
confidence to be flexible having the
confidence
to trade one type of position for
another
and just trusting that uh you know what
you're doing
you have to have a little bit of
confidence in yourself in order
to play chess like this because if
you're second guessing if you know
if i should just be be keeping with what
i know
then more often than not you're going to
be making concessions to keep the game
in into in something that you're
comfortable with you have to be willing
to be flexible and that's what these two
players just were not able
to do now i want to highlight one more
game
uh before we leave here and we're not
going to spend too long on it just
because we don't have that much time
oops spoilers you didn't see anything
um and it's going to be this game
between alejandra ramirez
uh another american chess living legend
as they say
and oscar mel donado who is also around
2200 feet in and i wanted to include
this game
because uh if you ask a grandmaster
what should i study to get better at
chess
a lot of the time the answer is end
games and this game
really is gonna highlight the importance
of having a good endgame understanding
and that's something that i think grand
masters just blow
master level players out of the water
with their understanding
of rook and games in particular is just
at such a different level
that it really helps you make decisions
in middle games so let's see how
alejandro uses his rook and game
knowledge here
in order to win this game against oscar
we have a fairly normal opening we get a
king's indian
uh kind of a czech peer type of setup
with the pawn on c6
although the puns on e4 yet castles and
then we actually see d5 from oscar
meldano so
maldonado going for a bit more some
uh simplistic structure structures
exchange slav type stuff after c takes
e5 and c takes c5
in the game we see alejandra go 95 e6
bishop f4
just getting developed and black is
eager to trade off some pieces trying
negate this powerful knight on
e5 we see takes and takes now bishop b5
takes and takes now knight c6 and f4 by
white
and here i want to ask you guys
at home uh let's flip the board why
don't we
and you guys at home how do you feel
about
black's position right now how do you
feel about it
that's my question to you do you feel
good do you feel bad
do you feel okay we don't know
how do we feel
very cramped bad fair enough
so everybody feels bad about this
position it's not as bad
as you might expect though it's not as
bad
not the worst as super marco puts it um
and i tend to agree here so
obviously this bishop is going to be the
problem
for black but the good news is this
isn't an
unsolvable problem you can imagine a
future when this bishop lands
on the c6 square if black is able to
play
magically bishop d7 bishop c6 in these
two pieces like go elsewhere
then black is going to be perfectly fine
here now why is black going to be fine
because the structure is very very solid
black doesn't really have
any major weaknesses yet so if we can
just achieve this
one little maneuver by black then we
should be good to go
so what i want you to pay attention to
is what alejandro plays to try and make
sure this doesn't become a reality
uh first we start with knight e7 i think
black plays this move to try and stop
knight b5 to d6
maybe it's a bit better to bring the
rook into the game but 97 is fine
queen d2 and now queen c7 so already
um black is threatening to go bishop d7
and bishop c6
so chatroom what should we try to do to
stop it
what should we try to do to stop it here
so the chat room has the right idea once
again um
right now white's only advantage is
okay i might be exaggerating a little
bit but really white's only real
advantage
is the fact that this bishop has not yet
planted itself
onto c6 if you give black to tempe
i think this is dead equal yeah dead
equal even
stockfish agrees with me um no reason at
all black should be worse here
so how do you try to take advantage of
this undeveloped mission well of course
you need to open things up in the center
so alejandra understands this
he plays the move e4 and is hoping to
open up
miss diagonal and find counter play over
here before black finishes development
to his credit uh oscar does play pretty
well for the next few moves
and brings the rook to d8 we see a check
and now king
to g7 and now queen f2
so chats how should black play
to survive this there's really only
one option that i think keeps black
realistically in the game
what can we do and quickly we're running
out of time
so time's up chat room of course we need
to develop our bishop and get it out
to c6 so bishop d7 in this case i think
is the only real way
black can stay in the game and in this
case it's actually going to be us
upon sacrifice we see queen b6 maybe 6
bishop b7 or k7 bishop f3
we're actually just going to play bishop
c6 getting this bishop activated
at all costs you can imagine take take
in something like rf2 and black is going
to be worse here
but i don't think black is by any means
losing there's a lot
a lot of work left to do here with
whites
because we have this active a file and
we have control over this d
file for the moment as as well so black
is going to be able to get some counter
play
you know bring these pieces in place
something like b5 b4
cement this pawn on a2 as a weakness and
uh
black is by no means out of this game uh
if black plays bishop d7
now once again though it takes a lot of
guts and a lot of chess understanding to
play a move like bishop d7
and i think that's understanding that
oscar maybe did not
fully have or at least not the
confidence to go through with it
instead oscar trades the queens and now
it's not too late to play bishop d7
but the open b file is actually a lot
less good
than the open af file and white is
already sort of a tempo up on the other
line
with this rook on f2 ready to swing over
in double whack
so at this point black tries a5 and
tries his best to untangle
but it's just not going to happen we see
knight d5
rook d1 b6 king g1
bishop b7 and this is where rook end
game understanding
really comes into play so up to this
point
white has been playing just good solid
chess you know
using this advantage in development and
trying to turn it into something
uh and right now it's an advantage and
activity but
it can be difficult to convert these
kinds of uh
these kinds of positions right because
you know at any moment
given a couple tempi black is going to
be able to sort of resurrect this
position get the pieces in the game like
bishop a8
knight takes f6 it's on the cards
but in this case alejandro can calculate
out
what happens if i just trade everything
and try to win the rook end game
and it turns out that's exactly what
happens
in this position we take everything
alejandro plays e6
and after rookie eight we see takes
rookie rick d7
and takes and this is where
having good knowledge of rook end games
is sort of
invaluable right a player like me i look
at this position
i'm like oh white's up a pawn that seems
pretty good but if you
you know really put the question to me
and we're like is white winning in this
position
i wouldn't be able to give you uh uh an
answer
and by having such a good understanding
of rook end games
like gm's often do you are able to
evaluate
these kinds of decisions so much more
quickly and so much more easily
and whenever you find an out to a
winning end game
you can jump at that opportunity prevent
any other
complications and sort of secure
yourself a full point so that's what
alejandra does here
quickly i will show you the winning
technique he simply
brings his king in has the active rook
and
pushes his f pawn until it becomes a
queen
just pushes it right up the board and
black resigns
now in fairness i'm not sure
why black thought it was a good idea to
bring the king over to b7
and leave this past f-pawn but the
from my analysis it looks like this end
game is just dead dead lost anyways
um so there you have it uh quite a few
reasons why
um
sorry uh no we're good okay quite a few
reasons why
and uh why grandmasters are so much
stronger than master level players from
stuff like just being able to
be flexible stuff like having more
confidence in your
decision making abilities and then of
course just technical knowledge
does play quite a significant factor let
me know what you thought of this lecture
i had a blast going over these games i
think they were all
from the 2013 world open i love watching
these kinds of tournaments where gm's
take on slightly weaker opponents
just to see that gm level technique